now more than 180 people have been
killed in devastating flooding and
landslides in nepal and india parts of
the region are experiencing some of the
heaviest post-monsoon rains for years
rescue efforts have begun but the damage
is already immense
like ants drowning in water
that's what houses in the state of
uttarakhand in north india resemble
right now torrential rains and flood
waters have engulfed the region
destroying homes roads and bridges
and killing several people
flooding has also triggered landslides
in one case a home was buried
killing five members of the same family
rescue workers are trying to find the
missing and get people to safety
some have been airlifted
our rescue forces have been split into
multiple smaller teams and have been
deployed to several flood affected areas
on rafts on ropes the national disaster
response force has also deployed teams
we're also clearing several roads that
have been closed due to flood damage
flooding from monsoons is common in
these regions of uttarakhand
but scientists say the problem is made
worse by erratic rains due to climate
change
nearby construction projects are also
adding to the problem
for many their livelihoods have been
completely destroyed
around
the paddy crops of the villagers are
completely damaged and the fields have
washed away the roads are muddy
authorities are visiting the affected
areas with promises to help the most
vulnerable
our government is with the victims
farmers have faced huge losses we are
trying to quickly assess and provide
compensation
neighboring nepal has also been badly
affected
many people have died
residents in remote areas are still
waiting for help as rescue teams
struggle to reach them
but the rains are not stopping
and more is predicted in the coming days